[Musica]
vi accompagnerà in un viaggio nel tempo
e nello spazio per apprezzare insieme il
coraggio di cambiare idea
marengo 14 giugno del 1800
siamo nel pieno della seconda campagna
di napoleone in italia sulla riva
orientale della bormida attorno a
marengo sono accampati francesi guidati
dal primo console napoleone buonaparte
allora trentenne
sull'altra sponda gli austriaci guidati
dal generale phone mail us sono
accampati alla periferia di alessandria
all'alba napoleone temendo un
accerchiamento da parte degli austriaci
manda a parte le sue truppe a nord ea
sud guidate rispettivamente dai
cellulari gardan ed ese
in realtà gli austriaci alle 8 del
mattino varcano la bormida e marciano su
marengo frontalmente
sono le primissime ore di quel
pomeriggio del 14 giugno del 1800 e per
i francesi
sembra tutto perduto
al punto che il generale austriaco
anziano
fan melas manda vienna un dispaccio
annunciando la sua vittoria
il resto è storia
la battaglia di marengo è stata vinta
dai francesi un grosso successo sia sul
piano militare che sul piano politico
la svolta avviene alle due del
pomeriggio quando il generale diesel che
era stato mandato a sud viene richiamata
marengo perchè la situazione sta
volgendo al peggio e questo è lo scambio
di battute fra napoleone bonaparte e il
suo primo e più valido assistente
napoleone osserva che la situazione
molto critica ed è pronto a ritirare le
tutte des e dice questa è una battaglia
completamente perduta ma sono solo le
due del pomeriggio
e c'è tempo per vincere un'altra il
resto come ho detto è storia fumero
coraggio a noi posteri la sentenza
sicuramente des e mostra grande coraggio
tant'è che con lo stesso giorno morì
valorosamente in battaglia coraggiosa
anche napoleone che qui vediamo in star
le truppe al coraggio appunto
ma che cosa ha motivato questo coraggio
gli storici ci dicono che dese da sud
aveva portato non solo delle truppe
fresche ma anche delle notizie fresche
aveva infatti capito che gli austriaci
con la loro cavalleria sì lui l'eroe con
difficoltà nel terreni attorno alla
bormida che erano stati resi paludosi
dalle fitte piogge del pomeriggio
precedente e anche le truppe a piedi
erano molto provate dalla guerriglia
perché erano dovuti scappare dalla città
di montebelluna dove pure erano state
sconfitte qualche giorno prima e quindi
il vero coraggio è stato quello di
napoleone di cambiare idea da ritirarsi
ad attaccare questo è un esempio di
coraggio militare quello di cui si
occupa aristotele soprattutto nell'etica
nicomachea
leggiamo la virtù del coraggio è una
disposizione abitudinaria che riguarda
la scelta quindi per aristotele il
coraggio per tiene a una disposizione
d'animo siamo fatti o meno per avere
coraggio il coraggio e riguardo le
scelte le decisioni e su questo punto
torneremo più avanti
per ogni sto tra il coraggio è una virtù
che sta a metà fra due vizi la viltà e
la pusillanimità che è un difetto di
coraggio da un lato e la temerarietà o
l'audacia che è un eccesso di coraggio
pensiamo per esempio ai torrieri durante
le corride
dice aristotele il giusto mezzo non può
essere stabilito astrattamente e in modo
identico per tutti ma deve essere
adeguato al soggetto che lo ricerca
quindi d'accordo con aristotele ritengo
che il coraggio sia una caratteristica
soggettiva sia per chi compie delle
azioni coraggiose sia per chi legge e
interpreta il coraggio nelle azioni
degli altri del resto l'etimologia del
termine coraggio core abio avere cuore
sottolinea questo e 7 tutti sicuramente
d'accordo con me che il cuore è una
questione strettamente personale un
esempio di scelta pusillanime è quella
di don abbondio che nota al manzoni non
era nato con un cuor di leone e alle
minacce dei bravi perché questo
matrimonio
cosa da fare né domani né mai
risponde anteponendo a renzo una serie
di impedimenti dirimenti e prende tempo
per raccogliere informazioni e poi
davanti al cardinale federico borromeo
si giustifica il coraggio
1 se non ce l'ha mica se lo può dare
ma il vero atto di pusillanimità di non
abbonda è stato quello di non aver
cambiato idea quando si rende conto che
la sua decisione avrebbe recato
sicuramente torto ai promessi sposi
quindi il coraggio dentro uno ce l'ha o
meno siamo fatti o meno per avere
coraggio
ma il coraggio puoi venire anche da
fuori come ha dimostrato dese che ha
portato informazioni incoraggianti a
napoleone e quindi il termine fatti per
avere coraggio può essere interpretato
anche come fatti dati e informazioni
incoraggianti che mostrano delle
opportunità che un animo coraggioso sa
cogliere o evidenziano dei pericoli che
possono scoraggiare certe azioni
e infine il termine fatti per avere
coraggio può essere interpretato come
fatti di stupefacenti per avere coraggio
siamo ancora in guerra nel 1939 durante
la guerra lampo la con cui hitler invade
la polonia
le truppe della wehrmacht marciano per
72 ore ininterrottamente sulle ardenne e
gli storici gli dicono che probabilmente
a questi uomini erano stati dati dei
cocktail di affetta mine per dare loro
coraggio per allontanare la paura cosa
che probabilmente viene fatta anche con
i soldati bambini o con i kamikaze
come vi ho detto aristotele dice che il
coraggio per tiene alle decisioni e
allora cercherò ora di inquadrare il
coraggio nell'ambito della teoria delle
decisioni prese in condizioni di
incertezza e in particolare con
riferimento alla teoria dell'utilità
pesa e alla teoria del prospetto
quando un soggetto razionale si trova ad
agire in una situazione incerta
deve secondo la teoria della
massimizzazione dell'utilità attesa
prendere la decisione che massimizza
l'utilità delle cose scienze della
decisione stessa
facciamo un esempio supponiamo di dover
decidere se vaccinarsi o meno quindi
abbiamo due scelte alternative e
semplificando al massimo supponiamo che
nella realtà il vaccino funzioni o non
funzioni dove per funzioni intendo che
il vaccino sia efficace
sicuro non abbia effetti collaterali e
sia disponibile
ora
all'incrocio fra le possibili
alternative e gli stati della realtà ci
sono le conseguenze delle mie scelte nel
nostro caso abbiamo quattro possibili
conseguenze
e adesso dobbiamo attribuire un utilità
a ciascuna di queste conseguenze nello
specifico personalmente penso che se mi
vaccino e il vaccino funziona o
un'utilità molto alta
se invece il vaccino non dovesse
funzionare questa utilità è bassa e la
pago in termini di costi di effetti
collaterali ma è molto peggio se io
decido di non vaccinarmi una situazione
in cui il vaccino funziona perché in
questo caso il prezzo che pago e in
termini di vite umane di persone per lo
più anziane e così via attribuisco una
serie di preferenze alle possibili
conseguenze se queste preferenze sono
coerenti allora posso pensare che ci sia
una funzione una funzione di utilità che
ci permette di attribuire a ciascuna
conseguenza il suo valore e questa
funzione di utilità può essere concava
lineare o convesso a seconda della
nostra propensione al rischio
avversione o indifferenza e questa
utilità a che fare di nuovo con noi
stessi è una funzione soggettiva e che
può incorporare il coraggio il passaggio
successivo è quello di attribuire ai
diversi stati della realtà una
probabilità per esempio penso che la
proprietà che il vaccino funzioni sia
del 90 per cento questa probabilità è
una proprietà soggettiva che possa
esprimere a priori basandomi sulla mia
esperienza passata oppure posso
raccogliere dei dati delle informazioni
e allora passa da una probabilità a
priori a una priorità a posteriori
naturalmente possono raccogliere
informazioni solo se sono in una
situazione di pensiero lento e ho il
tempo di raccogliere dati
se invece devo prendere una decisione
veloce
come per esempio se devo decidere una
situazione di pericolo se tuffarmi o
meno per salvare una persona che sta
rischiando di annegare non ho tempo di
raccogliere dei dati e allora ragiono
usando delle euristiche che tranne ma
premio nobel per l'economia e i tuoi ski
dicono che sono delle scorciatoie
mentali ma la cosa importante è che le
probabilità sono dinamiche nel senso che
ogni volta che arrivano nuove
informazioni le aggiorno ma nonostante
siano soggettive non sono arbitrarie
perché dei principi di coerenza elimina
l'arbitrarietà
calma nei tuoi scheme evidenziano però
che nel momento in cui noi prendiamo
delle delle decisioni in una situazione
incerta ci scostiamo un po da quello che
prescrive la teoria della
massimizzazione dell'utilità ci sono
delle discrepanze e superano queste
discrepanze dicendo che ciascuno di noi
individua dei punti di riferimento
cognitivi che fungono da termini di
paragone che servono per valutare le
conseguenze delle nostre decisioni e
questi punti di riferimento queste
prospettive sono necessariamente
individuali hanno a che fare con le
informazioni che abbiamo a disposizione
alla nostra propensione al rischio e in
ultima analisi anche con il coraggio
quindi riassumendo il coraggio a che
fare nell'ambito della teoria delle
decisioni razionali sia con la nostra
valutazione delle probabilità sia con la
nostra funzione di utilità sia con la
prospettiva sulla base della quale
valutiamo le conseguenze delle nostre
azioni
ma non dimentichiamoci che il coraggio e
anche un emozione e che come tale può
con turbare un po la nostra razionalità
e le conseguenze di un emozione sono
difficilmente prevedibili
nel momento che stiamo vivendo in cui ci
troviamo a combattere una guerra
mondiale nel senso di globale contro dei
nemici invisibili come il covip o
l'anidride carbonica nemici che non
conoscono confini
e fondamentale che le nostre decisioni
siano basate su dati solidi e che
abbiamo il coraggio di cambiare idea
ogni volta che emergono nuove
informazioni
consistenti e coerenti basate su dati
affidabili
questo è quello che ci dice la scienza e
con la scienza al nostro fianco
riusciremo a vincere questa battaglia
certo sui vaccini i nostri decisori
hanno cambiato idea più di una volta ma
anche la scienza ha rivisto i risultati
delle sue analisi alla luce di nuovi
dati che man mano emergano e questo
revisione delle
prescrizioni può lasciare un po
sconcertati e anche noi scienziati
dovremmo imparare meglio a valutare ea
esprimere l'incertezza delle nostre
previsioni e delle nostre ricerche
incertezza che può essere più o meno
ampia a seconda che i dati siano più o
meno affidabili e più o meno numerosi ma
i dati sono incoraggianti sia in termini
di casi che in termini di decessi sia in
italia sia nel mondo e quindi coraggio
perché i dati sono incoraggianti
questo è il mio modo di dare a voi
coraggio poi naturalmente il coraggio
dentro uno se lo deve trovare da solo
[Musica]